how are you feeling I mean this is
obviously like I suppose the chair on
the top of a really big successful year
in La all across the US and yeah so
literally how you feeling about it and
you know what's next I guess
um I think
probably overwhelmed at the moment I I
definitely wasn't expecting to
get this I think being nominated for
stuff like this kind of really feels
like the winning part being recognized
by your peers and stuff and
um
it's obviously incredibly nice to to
receive this
um I don't think it's the reason that
any of us in the room do it I'm so so
grateful that
um they thought our album was worthy of
it and uh
you know I think more than anything like
the
it it just kind of feels like
validation that you're on the right path
in choosing to you know when we get in
the studio and begin a record we just
make the music that we want to make and
I think
it's feels really nice to feel like oh
that is the right thing to do and
um
yeah it's uh it's crazy I'm really
really proud of these two guys
um
and everyone that made the album with me
and I just will continue to say you know
this one was for my friends I couldn't
have done it without the support of my
friends and
people in my life who made me feel like
I could make whatever I wanted and uh
yeah I'm very very grateful so cheers
thank you celebrate living tonight yeah
I'll I'll do my best
our next question is going to be virtual
let's go to ABC News
Andrea
oh yes Harry congratulations uh you guys
congratulations thank you Harry so much
so much of this album has been not just
the album but how you've performed it
live and how you've taken the songs to
the fans live can you talk a little bit
about how the songs transformed in your
feelings about this one's transformed as
you've been playing this tour that's
been so important
yeah I think the the beauty of music is
obviously you live with an album for so
long as you're making it and I've always
loved performing so much it's always
been my favorite part of working in
music and
um I've been able to really like fall in
love with the album making process to
which
you know now that's kind of one
love of my life and then playing it as
the other one and it's um
it's amazing to kind of see the way the
songs that mean so much to me you get to
kind of see what it means to other
people while you're playing it for them
and
it's um
I'd say in terms of that just I'm so
grateful to my fans who have created an
environment for me where
I feel like I can make just what I want
to make and
um
yeah I just feel so free when performing
and and that's a real gift and and I
love it so
that's that's what I'd say I think I
think that was an answer to the question
just words
lots of words
our next question is going to be in the
far back right in the bow tie
if you can get a mic over there
thank you so much my name is Ricky
Cornish without magazine hi Harry
Cornish how are you very well thanks how
are you so well Harry I have to
congratulate you my friend I think it's
safe to say that there are so many
people out there who have been listening
to you for years and they have gone to
so many of your shows and they finally
feel seen and less alone thanks to the
art that you have created throughout the
years knowing that you've made maybe one
person out there feel a little less
alone and seen thanks to your win
tonight how does that make you feel
um I think
I think the
you know the kind of atmosphere that is
created in
live music and and the kind of
experiencing of that is something that
you know when there's someone on stage
it feels like oh that's what that person
is doing and in reality I very much feel
like the fans create that atmosphere for
me and
it's kind of
the room is is this energy that
almost feels like too magical for me to
kind of take any responsibility for I
think it's
probably the thing I'm proudest of in my
life is this this feeling that is in the
room that I get to experience every
night when I go on stage and
um yeah it's it's probably
like the greatest I mean playing for an
amazing group of people every night is
my favorite favorite thing to do so
thank you thank you our next question is
going to be virtual let's go to Katie at
billboard
hi Harry congratulations thank you very
much
um I want to ask a lot of the narrative
going into tonight was about maybe it
was the night Beyonce was gonna win
album of the year so I just want to want
to ask you if you were expecting that as
well
yeah I think I think um
I mean you never know with with you know
this stuff I think there's no
I don't think you can look at any of the
nominees and
not feel like they're deserving I feel
like when you look at a
you know when I look at this category
it's all people have inspired me at
different times so it's not like
you know you would understand anyone
winning
um and
yeah I'm really grateful that they chose
us I'm not yeah thank you
all right we're going to do our last
question
um right up here in front for variety do
you want to take this one
do you want to take this one
kind of for all of you thanks
um hi I'm Elisa variety congrats thank
you I know you've been touring all over
the world like crazy but have any of you
had time to write or think about what
the next era of Harry Styles will be
I think it should look a lot more like
me to be honest yeah I think um
I think in terms of
we've always tried to not really stop
writing because it feels like you have
this big stop and then you come back to
it and can feel like you're either
trying to prove something or trying to
follow something up so
we're kind of just always writing and
like to attempt to
kind of have the same intention behind
what we're making and
um
you know I guess is
I don't know yeah yeah
I don't yeah sorry or I could just do it
he could just do it
um but
yeah I'm um
yeah
thank you
[Music]